[Music]
oh my friend Drew I'm jealous you have
an entire hour dedicated to George
Clooney I lied down on the floor and
um you know he was Dr George so we just
Dive Right In did you tell me about this
problem you have with handsome men that
are funny I've come to you at 47 realize
I have a new motto if you don't work we
don't work he was so open so funny he's
one of the most Charming if you look up
Charming in the dictionary there's
George's picture absolutely all right
guys here we go
I was in the first film he directed
called Confessions of a dangerous mind
I'm giving you one more chance get it we
had history and yet I'm just as excited
to be talking to George Clooney as
someone who hasn't had the privilege of
meeting him do you know that this movie
turns 20 in December Drew oh my gosh
that's so cool I didn't realize that I
want you to take a look at your time on
the set with George look at this oh no
she went through all of those same
elements that you get from early Fame
she did all of that when she was six you
know she just lights up a room from the
day she got to the set was a better set
to be on because she was there oh my God
I never saw that I thought that's so
nice you know he was really protective
of me I just gotten a divorce with Tom
and I you know he kept reminding me of
like how vulnerable I was at that time
and how much like he wanted to step in
and make sure I was okay and he played
my therapist did he give you and um
you know
for me looking at him and the way that
he kind of held out for the right one is
really good dating advice for all of us
she did say you gave great relationship
advice I think she's doing better now
yes have you always been good at giving
relationships clearly not I couldn't
even give myself
one of the things that that actually
surprised me that he and them all write
each other in love letters I started
writing her
you wrote her a bunch of letters like on
pen and paper yeah oh we still write
letters you
the universe we leave them on the pillow
oh my gosh that's one of the things that
really took my breath away it's so
unbelievable that they do this so let
them be a model to us all all of us
women are saying when we meet the man
who nobody thinks will commit and they
do commit what happens with him I asked
him genuinely I feel like with on the
mall you've kind of it's a no-brainer it
was definitely her and he really gave me
an interesting insight as to what their
courtship was like there's an
old-fashioned love that continues on in
their marriage and their Parenthood that
I think it seems like a lot of us lose
sight of
foreign